Дедалі більше жителів України змушені залишати країну через повномасштабну війну, розв’язану Росією.
За даними ООН, Україну вже покинули близько 350 тисяч людей. Кількість біженців продовжує зростати, як і охочих прийняти їх у різних країнах ЄС.
Тільки до Польщі, як каже влада цієї країни, прибули 100 тисяч біженців.
Люди добиралися до Перемишля дві доби замість звичайних двох годин.
Дуже важко виїхати, дуже. Особливо з маленькими дітьми. Але ж ми якось приїхали... Я спокійна за дітей, але переживаю, що в Україні залишилася сім'я.
Чоловік поки що залишився там, а в мене діти.
А чоловіки готуються: будують блокпости, обладнують бомбосховища, привозять потрібні речі до школи, церкви.
На вокзалі у Перемишлі біженців забезпечують найнеобхіднішим. Волонтери роздають тут гарячі обіди.
Місцеві жителі також привозять продукти харчування та предмети особистої гігієни. Прибулі можуть тут переночувати.
Цій біженці - 82 роки, вона народилася у Польщі. Каже, ніколи не могла подумати, що їй доведеться тікати назад до Польщі.
На запитання, чому Путін напав на Україну, у бабусі - своє пояснення.
Та він хворий, йому чогось не вистачає. Якби він був мудрий, то він би не почав війну.
21 століття на світі! 80 років тому закінчилася Велика вітчизняна війна. А йому треба було війну починати? Що він не розуміє скільки людей загине?
Біженцям з України безкоштовно допомагають місцеві жителі. Біля вокзалу стоять волонтери, які пропонують довести до польських міст, хтось до Берліна.
Дехто пропонує навіть житло. Теж безкоштовно. Наприклад, Марчин з Познані може дати притулок трьом і зварити смачну каву.
Я можу забрати сім'ю або 3 особи. У мене є можливість допомогти.
Я можу надати житло, звичайно ж, безкоштовно на якийсь час, але поки що я тут нікого не знайшов.
Крім того, у центрі Перемишля працює Український народний будинок у Польщі. Тут також тимчасово приймають українських біженців.
Ми допомагаємо дістатися пункту прийому біженців, де їх реєструють,
де їм надають транспорт, який доставить їх до місць призначення, до знайомих або родичів.
Серед тих, хто зустрічає українців у сусідній Польщі, не лише поляки.
Цей німець проїхав понад 1000 кілометрів до польсько-українського кордону, щоб допомогти біженцям.
Ми спостерігали за тим, що відбувається, ми побачили це по телевізору, моя донька і я.
І ми сказали: це так жахливо, ми хочемо зробити невеликий внесок, навіть якщо він малий. Але ми віримо, що це може на щось вплинути. (…)
Ми хочемо відвезти когось до Франкфурта. Ми також можемо забезпечити проживання до шести людей.
Українських біженців німці радо зустрічають не лише на польському кордоні, а й у самій Німеччині.
Приміром, на вокзалі у Берліні Віту і ще багатьох українців вітають волонтери.
Це питання, яке мені дуже близьке до серця. Мій тато та його сім’я прибули до США як біженці із Сомалі, а я наполовину німкеня.
Я знала, що якщо буде криза і люди приїдуть, я буду їм допомагати, тому що інші зробили це для моєї власної родини.
У мене багато фруктів, батончиків, мюслі, кренделів і горіхів. Прості речі, які я можу роздати, коли люди знаходяться на шляху до наступного місця.
Перша хвиля українських біженців лягла на плечі волонтерів. Але тепер уже відреагували і пропонують прихисток українцям адміністрації міст,
громадські організації, компанії перевізники тощо.
Наприклад, ось ця місцева благодійна організація у Фрайбурзі допомогла евакуювати майже 160 дітей з-під Києва.
Діти віком від 1 до 17 років прибули у супроводі 30 дорослих. Після 70-годинної подорожі вони у безпеці.
Мене переповнюють емоції. Коли чуєш ці розповіді…
Тим часом німецька залізниця та берлінська міська транспортна компанія скасували плату за квитки власникам паспортів України.
Безкоштовні квитки для прибулих з України пропонують також автобусні перевізники.
Наразі переважна більшість громадян України зупиняється у родичів чи друзів у Польщі, Словаччині, Німеччині чи інших країнах.
Підготовлені притулки для українців у Польщі та інших країнах ЄС ще не заповнені - поки що. Утім, ситуація може змінитися дуже швидко.
Європейський Союз обіцяє, що прийме всіх українських біженців від війни. ЄС готується уперше використати механізм про "тимчасовий масовий захист",
який має дозволити українцям проживання до 3 років і офіційну реєстрацію з правом на отримання медичного забезпечення і
освіту дітей без проходження складної процедури надання притулку.
Такий механізм розробили після воєн у колишній Югославії у 1990-х роках, однак так і не застосували.
Навіть під час кризи біженців у 2015 році. Рішення щодо цього Рада ЄС ухвалить 3 березня.
За оцінками ООН, найближчими місяцями близько 12 мільйонів людей в Україні та понад чотири мільйони українських біженців
у сусідніх країнах потребуватимуть допомоги і захисту. Організація закликала світ зібрати 1,7 мільярда доларів на допомогу українцям.